Google il va me faire trois annonces
majeures ils viennent de lancer le pixel
7 le pixel 7 Pro la pixel wash alors la
pixel watch on en parle dans quelques
jours on se la mets de côté on la
regardera et on laissera parce que je
pense que c'est une montre qui va être
extrêmement intéressante d'avoir du
Google au poignet on verra ça on en
reparlera tout de suite on se concentre
sur le pixel 7 et Pixel 7 Pro on se fera
le test aussi d'ici quelques jours donc
venez vous abonner si c'est pas déjà le
cas comme ça vous saurez tout quand ces
vidéos sortiront et puis plein d'autres
choses parce qu'il y a plein de trucs
très cool ici sur la tech je vous parle
de toutes les nouveautés les astuces
donc ça c'est bien abonnez-vous et
pensez surtout à actionner la cloche
google a lancé ces deux nouveaux
smartphones très intéressants qui
gagnent en succession des pixels 6 et
Pixel 6 pro sortie forcément l'année
dernière des formats légèrement
différents un poids aussi légèrement
différent on a plus de 200 g sur cette
pro et un petit peu moins de 200 g sur
le pixel 7 des couleurs aussi qui vont
varier alors on a deux couleurs en
commun on va voir l'Obsidian et le snow
qu'on va retrouver sur les deux modèles
mais sur le pixel 7 on a une couleur
exclusive c'est lemon grasse et le Azel
sur le pixel 7 pro des smartphones pour
tous les deux un verre cornichon la
glace victus qui va venir le protéger
contre les rayures et les chocs dans les
deux cas on trouve une dalle OLED
différence de diagonale 6,3 pour le
pixel 7 6,7 pour le pixel 7 Pro les
réseaux sont sensiblement les mêmes
20/9,5 9e ça change pas grand chose ce
qui va changer c'est la résolution on a
du Full HD plus sur le pixel 7 et quoi
d'acheter plus sur le modèle Pro haute
différence aussi c'est la techno on va
avoir une dalle ltpo sur le modèle
professionnel qui vous permettra d'avoir
un taux de rafraîchissement variable sur
le pixel 7 on va rester en 90 Hertz 90
Hertz tout le temps ou alors 61 ça sera
à vous de choisir tandis que sur le
modèle Pro votre smartphone va venir
switcher pour monter jusqu'en 120 c'est
lui qui le fera de façon complètement
intelligente et autonome on a dans les
deux cas des smartphones qui ont
luminosité de minites et qui monteront
jusqu'à 1400 ou 1510 en fonction du
modèle compatible tous les deux HDR à
gapet
très très sympa déjà le design est quand
même plus sympa le pixel 7 j'aime bien
le format qui est vraiment top le 7 pro
il est beaucoup plus léger beaucoup
moins massif donc j'ai hâte de voir au
quotidien on verra mais ça a l'air pas
mal
[Musique]
on a retrouvé dans un cas comme dans
l'autre des haut-parleurs stéréo ça
paraît que la moindre des choses trois
micro qui vont servir notamment pour de
la réduction de bruit lors de vos appels
téléphoniques et on a du Bluetooth 5.2
ok très standard moi j'adore tu vois le
transcripteur de message vocaux parce
que c'est des amis qui m'envoient des
podcasts je reçois 5 ou 6 messages
vocaux de 2 minutes d'affilée et c'est
super chiant de tout écouter tu es
obligé d'interrompre ta musique et tout
là ça te permet de tout lire donc
j'améliore un truc qui était déjà pas
mal donc c'est cool masqué
tout extrêmement intéressant c'est que
Google nous sort sa puce Google tensor
deuxième génération souvenez-vous
souvenez-vous on monte l'année dernière
c'était la première fois que Google
sortait une puce maison et qu'il se
passait des puces de Qualcom qu'on avait
l'habitude de trouver avant dans les
smartphones de Google plus maison
totalement optimiser aux usages de
Google ça va pas être la puce la plus
puissante en terme de gaming mais par
contre pour utiliser tous les services
Google et tout ce que Google a vous
proposer dans un smartphone et bien
c'est totalement optimisé et avec cette
puce on voit également arriver à la puce
de sécurité la Titan m2 également autant
vous dire qu'ici l'expérience est super
intéressante sur le papier on le testera
bien évidemment donc on regardera ça
d'ici quelques jours on va retrouver sur
le pixel 7 8 Go de RAM 12 gigas de RAM
sur le modèle professionnel c'est de la
lpdr 5 dans les deux cas ok très bien et
au niveau du stockage sur les deux
modèles on a 128 256 et sur le modèle
Pro on monte jusqu'à 512 Go de stockage
dans les deux cas c'est le fs3.1
ce modèle professionnel dans les deux
cas il y a pas de blocs de charge inclus
on peut venir recharger ici au maximum à
30 watts faudra bien racheter votre bloc
de charge en plus et en plus ici on est
compatible charge sans fil QI
l'autonomie que nous annonce Google ici
c'est 24 heures ça me paraît pas énorme
je pense qu'ils veulent pas trop se
mouiller on va pouvoir arriver un petit
peu plus loin on regardera ça bien
évidemment et après vous avez un mode
extra économie d'énergie donc j'ai mangé
le nom vous montez jusqu'à 72 heures
alors à ce moment-là sur ce mode là vous
aurez plus grand chose directement dans
votre smartphone de fonctionnelle
quelques applis essentiels mais si vous
n'avez pas la possibilité de venir vous
charger et bien vous allez pouvoir
pousser au maximum jusqu'à 72 heures
l'expérience Google c'est Android
Android pur pas plus pas moins mais
alors il y a un truc qui est intéressant
parce que là on retrouve également de
l'Android 13 sur plein de smartphones
Android c'est à dire or iPhone bien
évidemment et bien vous en avez un peu
plus déjà il y a un truc qui est
vachement bien et que nous fait Google
ce qui s'appelle les drop features c'est
à dire qu'ils vont pousser tous les
trois mois de nouvelles fonctionnalités
sans même que vous le sachiez à vous
d'aller lire fouiller et d'aller trouver
la dernière actualité pour voir ce qui
est arrivé directement sur votre
smartphone donc votre smartphone se met
à jour tous les trois mois avec de
nouvelles fonctionnalités spécialement
conçues pour Google je trouve ça
vachement bien en plus de ça vous avez
ici 50 mise à jour de sécurité je trouve
ça très rassurant sans oublier les mises
à jour Android qui vont bien évidemment
arriver dans le temps alors vous
connaissez Android 13 vous en ai déjà
parlé c'est pas le cas je vous renvoie à
ma vidéo on a toutes les évolutions
majeures qu'on avait avec Android 12
c'est-à-dire matériel you plus plein de
nouveautés très cool une fois de plus
allez voir ma vidéo est-ce que nous
rajoute ici Google ce sont des couches
de sécurité anti-fishing anti malware
ils vont mettre un VPN directement qui
inclut avec Google one alors là il
arrive pas tout de suite mais il
arrivera dans quelques temps donc je
trouve ça aussi bref une expérience
Software qui est très bien Android 13 et
ça on en reparle une fois de plus lors
du test comme d'hab avec Google c'est le
logiciel qui est le plus intéressant
donc tu as un produit qui est hyper
complet moi j'aime bien parce que c'est
la première année Google prend la
formule qu'ils avaient déjà fait déjà
fait l'année dernière mais il l'améliore
et c'est ce que font toutes les marques
en fait depuis des années et là on sent
que Google enfin trouvé sa voie et alors
ça révolutionne rien mais il y a quand
même les petits ajouts logiciels qui
rajoutent des trucs vraiment sympa
notamment le fait un Blur qui est assez
fou et le zoom j'ai hâte de l'essayer
parce que il a complètement dingue
je sais pas si vous le savez mais le
gros point fort des pixels depuis
plusieurs générations même d'ailleurs
depuis longtemps et bien c'est la photo
c'est là où ils sont extrêmement forts
pourquoi parce que vous avez derrière de
la photographie computationnelle c'est
quoi ce mot un peu barbare ça veut dire
qu'en fait vous avez tout l'algorithme
de Google qui va venir maximiser la
qualité de vos photos là où Google il y
a quelques années avait un seul objectif
là ils ont démultiplié les objectifs sur
le pixel 7 vous avez encore donc il y a
du très grand angle et sur le
professionnel vous avez en plus un
téléobjectif donc dans les deux cas on
retrouve un capteur de 50 mégapixels sur
le grand angle on ouvre à f1.85 et sur
le modèle cell vous aurez un zoom
numérique qui reste jusqu'à x 8 on
trouve également ultra grand-angle de 12
mégapixels 2.2 alors là il y a une
différence sur le pixel 7 vous avez un
champ de vision de 114 degrés tandis que
sur le modèle professionnel 125,8
°c va ouvrir davantage on en verra plus
sur les côtés une fois de plus on
redresse ça lors du test et sur le
modèle Pro vous avez un téléobjectif de
48 mégapixels qui ouvre à f3.5 avec un
zoom optique x5 et on va jusqu'à zoom
numérique x 30 de la stabilisation
optique de la stabilisation électronique
un capteur ldaf et puis une caméra de
selfie de 10,8 mégapixels tout bref deux
points de ok pas mal on regardera ça je
suis persuadé une fois de plus qu'ici
Google a frappé fort au niveau de la
photo et une fois de plus on le regarde
dans le test on peut faire également de
la vidéo c'est aussi un truc qui est
intéressant peut filmer que ce soit à
l'arrière ou à l'avant en 4K à 60 images
par seconde je suis quand même impatient
de tester sur toute la partie photo donc
la partie photo risque d'être assez
impressionnant je pense et puis voilà
quoi c'est c'est une évolution des pixel
6 je suis très curieux sur la partie
photo puisqu'on sait que Google sont
très très bons de base sur la partie
photo et sur les retouches des photos et
là il y a quelques technologies de
fonctionnalités qui sortent de
l'ordinaire à tester genre qui te permet
de transformer une image flou en image
nette et ça ça a l'air très cool donc à
tester
vous pouvez insérer ici une seule carte
SIM mais vous pouvez également avoir une
ici on a du wifi 6e c'est cool parce que
dans les iPhone 14 on n'a pas de wifi 6e
du NFC Google cast il est certifié IP68
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
bonne chance
tout le monde augmente le prix Apple ils
ont monté de 15 % eux c'est les mêmes
après je pense que c'est il faut quand
même un prendre la défense des autres et
pas taper gratuitement sur Apple et tout
c'est plus facile de ne pas augmenter
les prix quand on vend pas beaucoup que
quand on vend des millions derrière et
ou derrière c'est toi qui paye la
facture de l'inflation maintenant c'est
quand même hyper cool ça va peut-être
permettre à Google de continuer
d'augmenter ses parts de marché donc bah
je leur souhaite et ils sont dispo au
tarif 2 le pixel 7 649 euros ce qui
reste extrêmement bien positionné pour
voir que vous avez tout quasiment tout
sauf le téléobjectif sauf deux trois
trucs mais vous avez un super smartphone
à 649 € en tout cas sur le papier on le
testera bientôt tandis que le modèle Pro
le pixel 7 Pro est à 899 euros on a un
flag type on a le flag type de Google
qui est quand même en dessous des 1000
balles déjà mais surtout en dessous des
900 balles pas mal de main montre les
prix parce que le contexte économique
actuel etc et là on arrive quand même à
garder un téléphone qui est compétitif
avec l'autre gamme sur la partie spec et
produit et pourtant à 650 balles et là
franchement c'est ouf je trouve bien et
on va qu'une fois de plus les tarifs pas
monté il y a pas eu d'escalade parce que
la période emmène plutôt les tarifs à
monter ils sont assez contenus ici
aujourd'hui par Google ça reste cher ça
reste beaucoup d'argent on est sur du
premium ultra premium mais je trouve ça
une fois de plus très bien alors je sais
pas vous ce que vous en pensez dites le
moi en bas dans les commentaires comment
vous les trouvez vous oui comment est-ce
que vous les trouvez c'est Google pixel
7 et Pixel 7 Pro est-ce qu'il vous tente
et puis est-ce que vous avez envie
d'aller plus loin dans l'écosystème de
Google je pense notamment à la pixel
watch la montre connectée de Google et
aussi des pixel buzz bref il y a un
écosystème produit de Google qui s'étend
de plus en plus pour la maison les nest
homme nestup bref de tous les côtés je
sais pas si vous êtes vous client si ça
vous intéresse dites-le-moi en bas dans
les commentaires et puis on va continuer
bien évidemment à parler de Google les
gens on va tester ces produits puis on
va regarder un peu cet écosystème parce
qu'on peut faire avec Google parce que
c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
intéressant d'ici là prenez soin de je
vous embrasse et à très bientôt des
bisous Ciao